welcome to bananamores i can't even
contain my excitement for this next
comedian
all you people watching at home get
those hands of clapping
thank you thank you mitzi yes oh man
just happy i made it today because i'm
just so
hungover you know
sorry i mean i'm i'm pregnant i
i often get those two mixed up because
you know when you find out for both you
you just start throwing up
a bunch and then you swear off alcohol
for some time
and then you're always just like i'm
never doing that again
like never so this is our
second um coming at you
and i have one who he's is a toddler and
you know it's
it's quarantine it's been a trip but one
thing that i've learned
from this is it's beautiful to be around
children because you learn so much about
them and about yourself
and um the other day we were playing
peek-a-boo
which is his favorite game and uh we
were in the living room
we were by the uh the coffee table and
he was going down
and then he would come up and i'd be
like right he's delighted
and then he would go back down and he
would come back up and i was like oh my
god you were still a baby
and he was delighted and then one time
he just
he went down and stayed down
and uh i just heard him going
and i was like oh my gosh are you okay
are you okay and i looked over the edge
and he looked up at me and he was just
like
and then stood back up like it's your
turn mom and i realized
um he was pooping
like just mid his turn
in the game just squatted down and took
a deuce
and i was like i want
that confidence it's amazing that
feeling
and i think there's something special
about it especially being a woman
because society dictates that women you
know we shouldn't perspire
we shouldn't fart we shouldn't poop
like just don't don't let your bodies
work ladies okay
it's horrible like i don't know what men
do in public washrooms
because i've never been in them but i
assume it's like cross swords and talk
sports i don't know
but i'll tell you how it works in a
women's washroom
okay you walk into a woman's washroom
completely
dead silent like there's like tumble
weeds
rolling past and not because there's no
women in there oh
every stall is full okay but it's
because
every woman in there is waiting for
everyone else to leave
so that she can do her business oh and
we have the patience of saints do we not
ladies
like i've missed flights i've missed job
interviews because i'm like i'mma wait
everybody out
thank you guys so much for having me at
bananamores uh it's an absolute pleasure
back to you mitzi i can't even get over
how much talent this person has the
banana more stage is
lucky to have that one i'll tell ya